l'ambiance est à couper au couteau
le face à face à la fois redouté est
attendu par la famille de joyce et
chaque one a enfin lieu je me suis
choqué on nous traite comme des esclaves
des pions je sais que j'ai été super
méchante je regrette tellement je
m'excuse à sa famille et à mes confrères
de travail l'instant sanglots
l'infirmière aujourd'hui sans emploi
elle répète la paperasse la surcharge de
travail
une récente perte auditive les
contraintes liées à la coved elles
étaient à bout le fait qu'ils sont
fatigués surtaxé le fait qu'elle ait des
problèmes de santé ne justifie en rien
le langage qu'elle a utilisé à l'endroit
de adam jones et chaque coin la coroner
gn kamel est du même avis et
s'impatientent
particulièrement lorsque le témoin en
vient à la chute de la patiente aux
allures dit intentionnel qui aurait
provoqué son excès de colère je suis en
plein scénario surréaliste
il ya une femme qui va mourir devant
vous et vous ce qui vous vient à
l'esprit c'est il va falloir que je
fasse un rapport d'accident
son témoignage est imprécis difficile
d'y voir clair qui s'est passé entre le
moment où elle a été en fait le moment
où elle a filmé cette vidéo et le moment
où elle est tombée en détresse ont aussi
une série de photos niveau la
surveillance au niveau du monitoring au
niveau de la tension qui lui était
acquis qui lui a été accordé mais on n'a
toujours pas de réponse claire la vidéo
résonne à nouveau dans la salle à la
demande de la famille incrédule
importante
bien rafraîchir la mémoire importance
des paroles crues qui il avait été
mentionné
as tu un moment dans la salle les larmes
coulent encore infirmières maintient
qu'il s'agit d'un événement isolé
qu'elle n'est pas raciste et réitère ses
excuses je pense les gens qui se font
pas nié son point fort à l'issue de
cette journée déterminante la famille a
émis un communiqué affirmant que
l'absence de prise de conscience fait
mal
ecl incompréhensions subsistent dans
l'espoir d'obtenir des réponses d'ici le
2 juin
et si amélie desmarais radio canada
trois rivières